have two lines we'll just call these two
lines LM right and they're cut by a
third line which we're gonna call T
that's the transversal it transverses or
cuts across those two lines now we're
going to look at two different scenarios
here here you can see the lines are not
parallel but we're gonna look at when
the lines are parallel as well okay so
let's just say that these are parallel
we're gonna look at what happens but
first of all let's just talk about the
names so when you talk about
corresponding angles what that means is
see for example like see how this forms
like an X and see how this forms like an
X right here if you were to take this X
and place it on top of this X just slide
it down like that the angles that match
up with one another or correspond those
are called corresponding angles so you
can think of it like angle 2 and angle 6
like upper right hand corner upper right
hand corner
those are corresponding angles okay now
when the lines are parallel the
corresponding angle is upper right upper
right those are going to be congruent
those are gonna be equal to one another
okay same thing here one in five are
corresponding so the upper left upper
left three and seven lower left lower
left for an eighth lower right lower
right but just think about picking up
that X placing on that X the angles that
match up those are called corresponding
okay next we're talking about alternate
interior angles so interior means in
between these two lines so on the inside
right alter it means ones on the right
ones on the left so like four and five
are alternate interior angles three and
six are alternate interior angles now
when the lines are parallel like over
here the alternate interior angles are
going to be congruent meaning that
they're equal they have the same
measurement okay so if you think about
the name a lot of times I will tell you
or just remind you what it is alternate
means they alternate one left one right
interior there in between like on the
inside
now alternate exterior they're on the
outside so you can see one two seven and
eight these angles are on the outside of
the two lines here alter it means ones
on the right ones on the left so like
seven and two are alternate exterior one
and eight are alternate exterior when
the lines are parallel the alternate
exterior angles are going to be
congruent or equal okay
now the last one we're going to talk
about is consecutive interior angles
consecutive means like one after another
interior means in between so four and
six are consecutive interior sometimes
refer to as same side interior because
they're on the same side of the
transversal
okay so four and six and three and five
these are also consecutive interior now
consecutive interior angles are kind of
the oddball of the group in a sense that
when these lines are parallel the
consecutive interior angles the same on
this angle they're not equal like the
other ones we mentioned they're
supplementary meaning they add up to 180
degrees so this angle this angle add up
to 180 this angle this angle add up to
180 now I just want to mention one last
thing is that in this diagram when the
lines are parallel and they're cut by a
transversal even though you have a
angles okay like we have here eight
angles you only have two angle measures
so say for example this is 120 degrees
this is 120 degrees these are vertical
angles this is 120 degrees these are
alternate interior this is 120 these are
vertical this is 60 these are
supplementary they're a linear pair
these are 60 right because they're
vertical this is 60 here alternate
interior and then this is 60 because
these are vertical angles but again you
see there's only two angle measurements
even though there's eight angles so
again just remember that corresponding
alternate interior alternate exterior
those angles are gonna be congruent when
the lines are parallel and then
consecutive interior angles are going to
be supplementary they add up to 180 but
if the lines are not parallel they still
have those same names alternate exterior
alternate interior and so forth it's
just that the angles are not necessarily
congruent or equal so I hope this helped
you understand the terminology involved
with this geometry concept here
subscribe to the channel check out some
more math videos on my marios math tutor
youtube channel and i look forward to
seeing in the future videos I'll talk to
you soon